even in a campaign built out of
unintended irony there has been nothing
more ironic than questions about Hillary
Clinton's pneumonia and whether she
would be fit to serve still coming from
the campaign of an opponent who will not
denounce or even distance himself from
supporters who often shout that she
should be killed or hanged or shot for
treason we want you dead but we're
concerned that your health disqualifies
you from being elected well there is one
thing more ironic than that that Donald
Trump's point man on secretary Clinton's
health is Rudolph Giuliani Rudy
seriously the media quote fails to point
out several signs of illness by her all
you've got to do is go online and put
down Hillary Clinton illness take a look
at the videos for yourself dr. Rudy
Giuliani Rudy do you even remember when
you ran for president yourself starting
in 2006 when you were still considered a
short term survivor of prostate cancer
do you remember anybody then saying it
was disqualifying in any way do you
remember anybody saying that the
possibility of recurrence at a chance
that you might have cancer anywhere else
in your body that that might make you
unfit to seek the highest office in the
land did any of your opponents have the
gall to attack you over your own health
did any of your opponents do that when
you were first diagnosed while you were
running for that Senate seat from New
York whoo all right Hillary Clinton
the New York Times April 28th 2000
this's Clinton spoke to the mayor by
phone yesterday while campaigning in the
Finger Lakes district and wished him
according to her press secretary Howard
Wolfson a quote speedy recovery the
mayor who has been sharply critical of
both mrs. Clinton and the Clinton
administration in recent weeks said
thank you
according to mr. Wolfson the
conversation mr. Wolfson said lasted one
minute what the hell Rudy
that doesn't sound like
attack on you for not addressing your
health sooner or having the media cover
it up for you what about when you had to
drop out of the race because of the
cancer again the New York Times make
twentieth two thousand mysteries
announcement said afterward I certainly
hope and pray as I know all New Yorkers
do that he will have a full and speedy
recovery what do you mean she didn't say
you were hiding something what do you
mean she didn't start chanting lock him
up lock him up more from 16 years ago
asked if she would miss the mayor as an
opponent mrs. Clinton replied well I
think we should just wish him well as a
person wait where's the reference in
there to your marital scandal that was
going on at the same time I mean you're
saying she didn't accuse you of using
your health as an excuse she didn't
claim that you were really dropping out
because ten days earlier you had
announced you wanted a separation from
the missus and left her to conduct a
tearful news conference outside the
gates of the mayor's mansion in New York
and by the way Rudy if you have
permission to diagnose Secretary Clinton
from videos you saw on the internet
maybe it got that permission from
Trump's position dr. Vinny boombots
may I suggest that having seen you in
person several times over the last 15
years to say nothing of all those videos
I saw of you on the Internet it sure
looks to me from I completely and
utterly unqualified position as a not
doctor that you have been waging a
losing battle against ever increasing
symptoms of post-traumatic stress
disorder
Rudy Giuliani who only kept his job as
chief Clinton health rumormonger because
while Newt Gingrich was on the air
spewing to Sean Hannity about Clinton's
coughing fits Gingrich had a coughing
vet oh and then there's Tom Brokaw dr.
Tom Brokaw who threatened by the
Republicans that their candidate would
not show up to the debate he was
moderating unless he got me and Chris
Matthews thrown off MSNBC coverage of
the 2008 debates not only care
that particular barrel of GOP water but
then boast about it in the papers Tom
Brokaw saying one hour after the
pneumonia overcame Secretary Clinton
inside the 9/11 ceremony quote this
morning I had a rather detailed message
from a Republican who was inside and he
was raising questions as well as saying
I don't know if this is hmm but here the
incidents that we are all watching I
don't think that she should go to a
hospital see a neurologist and get a
clean report never hey Tom I worked with
you for nine years they asked me if I
wanted you on cable coverage of the
primaries and I said of course I think
you should go to a mirror and see if you
have any journalistic credibility left
it was pneumonia bad guess Tom for
crying out loud
Hillary Clinton has been campaigning
with pneumonia since at least last
Friday and making more sense per minute
that Donald Trump has in his entire
campaign
how's her health she's freaking Wonder
Woman